hey David what is worse after what
happened in Iowa this last week the
electoral college or the caucus system
which is more broken well what's
interesting about the electoral college
system in the caucus system is that
aside from the ways in which they leave
themselves open to manipulation that's
not what I'm gonna deal with today
they're kind of broken in the same way I
mean one so with Iowa the complaints
came around you know the app that was
used the reporting the sketchy way in
which how wasn't it tested fully like we
get all that stuff but really when it
comes down to it Bernie Sanders won the
popular vote in Iowa but did not get the
most number of Delegates that is a
similar problem to winning the popular
vote nationally and not winning the
electoral college Hillary Clinton
winning by several million votes and
Donald Trump still winning the electoral
college the problems are very similar
they're broken in in very similar ways
now you can argue that the caucus system
is less obviously a disaster at a state
level because you can conceivably still
handle an election at the state level
under that caucus system which would
just be absolute and total chaos
nationally but that's not what we're
comparing we're comparing caucuses and
States and the electoral college system
nationally I think that the electoral
college system has had more of an impact
in elections if you look at the number
now of Republican presidents who have
one electoral II but lost the popular
vote that is a system that has handed
numerous presidencies to the Republican
Party when you look at the caucus system
in states there's no question that
between the coin flips and winning the
popular vote but losing the delegate
count at the state level there have been
effects from having the caucus system
but as far as I was able to research
going back about 30 years the caucus
system has not flipped who ultimately
was the nominee in the Democratic Party
super-delegates have been a big part of
that that's separate from the caucus
system you can look at that as something
that has actually changed the outcome of
who is the Democratic nominee but the
caucus system has not flip
the results in the way that the
electoral system nationally has giving
the presidency to multiple Republicans
who actually lost the popular vote so if
you ask me
which has been worse in terms of its
impact I have to say that it's the
electoral college system changing either
or both has its quirks of course states
often although debt although the
Democratic and Republican parties are
not government institutions and they can
run their primary however they want
States often have laws about when their
primary is or how it works so New
Hampshire has to be the first primary
Iowa has to be the first to vote at
least eight days before any primary
which is why February 3rd was the day of
the Iowa caucus and eight days later
February 11th is the day was the day of
the New Hampshire primary so you can
change that at the state level to get
rid of the electoral college system of
course you would either need a
constitutional amendment or it could
happen to facto through something called
the NPV IC national popular vote
interstate compact states can decide
unilaterally how to award their
electoral votes and a state for example
Texas could say we don't care which
candidate wins Texas we are going to
give our delegates to the winner of the
National popular vote if you get enough
states to do that that they some 270
electoral votes you create a de facto
national popular vote that seems by far
the most viable and likely way we could
get a national popular vote you are not
going to see you know when you've got to
have a two-thirds vote in the Senate and
three-quarters of the states say let's
get rid of the electoral college all of
the red states that know that they've
had multiple presidencies handed to them
by the electoral college they're not
going to do it so something like the NPV
IC would really be the only likely way
that I see of getting rid of the
electoral college and switching to a
national popular vote let me know what
you think we've got a great bonus show
today get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at join
pakman.com or a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show one of our
sponsors is privacy calm they're giving
you five dollars when you sign up for
their completely free service at privacy
calm slash Pakman I've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cashback and
lets you create thirty six credit cards
a month and a twenty five dollar a month
plan tailored more for small businesses
where you can create sixty card numbers
a month and much more but definitely go
ahead and at least get started with the
free plan you'll protect your financial
info companies can't charge you
unexpectedly and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy calm slash Pakman